I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. And today we are going to be talking all about Oscar Martinez. And we are really excited because we have Oscar Nunez in the studio
today answering all of your questions about his character. I've been looking forward to this one. Well, it turned out great. Spoiler alert, we had the best time with Oscar. We had the best time. So here's what we're going to chat about. He's going to answer questions about the office and the paper, which has its season two debut on Peacock today, September 9th.
But first, we're going to share all about Oscar. Jenna, you're going to discuss the show Bible. We're going to talk about Oscar favorite moments. I'm going to share three. her personality traits that fans say they love about them. It's good stuff, lady. All right. Why don't you go first?
Sure. So I haven't been in the show Bible in a little while. Because we haven't done one of these all abouts. Was it dusty? You know what? Can I tell you? I have been using my digital version of the show Bible. I found it in my digital clutter.
Look at you go, girl. I know. I thought you would be proud of me. I'm proud. I said, is it dusty because that's something my mom would say, like, if you go into someone's house and their Bible's dusty. Oh, that is so funny. I haven't been to church in a bit. I like that. Okay, well, so first of all, every time you have a character name, it will also tell you their address. Now, if their address has been written or scripted as part of the show, they just have the address. But if their address has been made up by the art department, it says per the art department. So Oscar has a per the art department address. Which means it was never used in the universe of the show on camera.
Right. He did have one. He did. And also what they would do, I had this and we all had this, they would make us wallets, credit cards. Driver's license. And they would put this address on those documents until they were told otherwise. I'm so curious if when Dwight is sneaking around spying on office. Oscar and Gill if there was the address on the house.
Oh, that's a good question. I bet the number on the house does not match this address per the art department. Let's see. What was it? It lists his address as 1327 Pear Street. Oh, Pear Street. Mm-hmm. All right.
I am looking up Oscar and Gill's house, and the numbers on the house say 5232. Mm-hmm. So that is a deep cut fan catch right there. Yep. And, you know, that house was in Van Eyes. It's on a lot of people's drive and find office spots. Yes. So was not 1327 Parr Street. Was not. But if Oscar opened his wallet, that's what you'd see. Oh, hey, everyone. By the way, Sam just found us the Google Maps for 1327 Parr Street and Scranton. And it looks. looks like an abandoned something called rush hours. Sam, did you say it looks like a bar? Yeah, it looks like a former bar. Yeah, it has no trespassing signs. A long time ago.
Well, there you go. Did we just mom detective that? I think we did. Well, we Sam detected did. We did. Thank you, Sam. But in true mom detective form, there's no real answer. No real solution. It is what it is. It is what it is. All right, well, digging into what the show Bible says about Oscar, there is not a lot about his family of origin, but we do know a few things. We know that his parents were both born in Mexico. They moved to the U.S. a year before Oscar was born. So we know that Oscar was born and grew up in the United States. We know that he has a nephew. He also has an aunt that lives in Carbondale, and we know that his mother is now in a wheelchair. We know that Oscar speaks Spanish.
but he is not good at doing accents. You know, when we're doing the murder mystery, he tries to do the accent. He's very, very bad. Very bad. We know that Oscar has a timeshare in Key West and he drives an SUV. We also know that Oscar likes yoga, long lunches,
and is one of the founding members of the Finer Things Club. He's pretty physically fit since he can pull himself up into the ceiling during the fire drill and he likes doing ab work. Mm-hmm. He is also a very good ice skater. and he hates posters of babies playing jazz. That's one of the things he very much disliked.
Very, very much not a fan. When Oscar was younger, he wanted to be an actor in commercials. But as you know, he ends up in the accounting department at Dundermifflin. We don't really know how he got from aspirations of being an actor to becoming an accountant. And we do have a very fun conversation with him later about who exactly is the head accountant. Or who he thought it was going into it. And in season four, he says he's been at Dunder Mifflin for nine years, but in season five, he says he's been at Dunder Mifflin for eight years. Oscar, do the math, buddy.
He also owns a little Dunder Mifflin stock, we come to find out. And his nickname in the office is actually. We know that Oscar is gay. He has a longtime boyfriend, Gill. And when they break up, he becomes interested in Matt from the warehouse. And then he eventually begins an affair with the senator who is married to Angela at the time. State Senator. State Senator. And then Oscar announces he has plans to run for state senator, but we find out that instead he ends up in the accounting department of a small Toledo newspaper.
Nicely done, lady. I love a good show Bible. Yeah. A nice overview of the character. Well, Ant, I'm curious to hear what these Oscar personality traits are that fans love. Okay, well, this all started with a letter from Alexandra A in San Antonio, Texas. Alexandra said, Hi, office ladies, I have watched the office all the way through three times, and each time I find new things to love about Oscar. In my opinion, he is the best at throwing shade. My BFF thinks it's Phyllis or Angela, but I say no, it's Oscar. And I have a favorite, or at least a favorite, for right now.
I'm sure it will change, but it's when Ryan is getting arrested and goodbye Toby, and then Alexandra typed out her favorite quote, but I think Alexandra, let's hear Oscar do it rather than me read it because he's going to do it better. Well, this is what happened. Ryan's big project was the website, which wasn't doing so well. So Ryan, to give the impression of sales, recorded them twice, once his office sales and once his website sales, which is what we refer to the business as, misleading the shareholders. Another good term is fraud. The real crime I think was the beard. I love that. Alexandra goes on to say that gets me every time. Love you ladies, and I'm so excited for this episode. I mean, that's a pretty classic Oscar throwing shade. The beard. The beard. Yeah, that's pretty great. So Alexandra, you weren't alone and loving the Oscar shade, and this led me to dig into the other personality traits that people chat about online about the character of Oscar, there are two more that get a lot of chatter.
Okay. Okay. There is an overwhelming consensus online that he is also the voice of reason on the show. Oh, we talk with him about that. Yeah, right? Listen, Oscar Martinez, the character, he knows it. He even calls it out in this talking head. Let's hear it.
All right. Who else is here? Pam and Jim are on their honeymoon. So there's not the usual balance between sane and others. Toby has mentally checked out since June. It's a very dangerous time. The coalition for reason is extremely weak. Sane versus others.
It really made me laugh. That's a combo. That's being the voice of reason and shade. Oh, you're right. You're right. That's a combo platter. Combo platter. Okay, the third personality trait that everyone online talks about
for the character Oscar is, he is the office know-it-all. Actually. Actually. And here's a fan-favorite moment where he corrects Meredith. Always with the friends, Oscar. Can't we just enjoy the new espresso machine? Actually, it's pronounced espresso. Wait, that's what you said.
I apologize. I just assumed you would mispronounce it. So I guess that's also know-it-all slash shade. Yes. Exactly. I think everything is slashed shade when it comes to Oscar. Well, listen, now it's time for us to share our favorite Oscar moments. Sam, do you want to go first? Sure. So I think Oscar plays drunk so well. It's my favorite thing he does in the show. We got so much mail about that. We talk with him about that. Yes. So all time in the ranking goes when him and Andy call Angela.
That's more of a visual gag. So this is a solid second for me. And I am Bacchus friend. It's his laugh before it. It's completely unhinged. Is that at the pool party? Yes, it is, yeah. I am Bacchus God of One. So good.
Okay, Jenna, what about you? Well, I have a lot of favorite Oscar moments, but I love, for personal reasons as well, the Oscar Pam Angela Dynamic in the cold open for season eight after hours. Here is the clip. Hey, Angela. You want to see a picture?
of Philip wearing those little booties you got us? So cute. Hey, you guys want to see a picture of Gerald wearing galoshes? He refused to go out in the rain until I bought these. Now going out in the rain is all he wants to do. Oscar thinks having a dog is just like having a baby. Newsflash, if you didn't carry it around in your belly for nine months, it isn't your kid. Exactly.
Unless you adopted, of course. That is where we disagree. Hey, are your little dudes crawling yet? No. Three-month-old humans don't do that. My Philip is crawling. Angela is such a liar. It's maddening.
Exactly. That's just like crate training. All night long, all night long. Well, count yourself lucky. Wait until you have two. That's two sleep schedules. Two naps that don't coincide. I mean, you'll never sleep again. No one said you must have two.
Like her genes are so important. The world just needs more Pam Jim DNA. Thank you, no. No. Thank you. Check this out. My brother just got a new sailboat. He has no idea what he just got himself into.
There's nothing harder than take care of a boat. Am I right? Unbelievable. Unbelievable. Unbelievable. So there it is. I just love how we were all teamed up. Oh yeah, and then being so catty.
I know. So it's like we're having this three-way conversation, but then we're pairing off to bitch about the other one. So much sidebar. Yes. Matt, it's your turn. I had to go with gay witch hunt. It's just the first thing that comes to mind.
And it's just these seven words that Oscar says. I'll let the clip speak for itself. I was going to quit. But Jan offered me a three-month paid vacation and a company car. All I had to do was sign something saying I won't sue. Gill and I are going to Europe. kids sometimes it pays to be gay it's so great
I also just wanted to say that episode you both are so amazing Angela you're so mean to Oscar I know and Jenna your face when Michael is trying to kiss Oscar is just amazing you're both so great in that episode I rewatched that scene in the conference room earlier today and I fully saw
Phyllis break. Oh, yeah. In the background. There's no hiding it. She fully breaks. Yeah. Yeah. All right, Angela, what about you? Okay. Well, I do love how many times Oscar gives people shade so much. I didn't pick any of them. I just have to go on record saying I love it. Anyway, just putting that out there. So the other thing I love is when people go to Oscar for advice. And we talked about that a little bit with him are when Oscar gives unsolicited advice. Amazing. So I went with this moment from Garage Sale in season seven. It's just the perfect little Oscar moment to me.
And to jog your memory, Pam, Ryan and Jim and Oscar are all in the conference room with Michael, and they're going to help him figure out how to propose to Holly. Okay? And here's what Oscar says. So we want to help you plan the proposal so that it's safe and responsible and realistic and doable. I had a great idea until you ruined it. You want to know how to do it. Here's how you do it.
Take her out to dinner, go down on one knee. If you are in costume, you did something wrong. If at any point you find yourself tying the ring to a dog's collar, stop and look at yourself. Like Pam's set up and then Oscar just jumping in and he knew he would try to be a character. Yes. And costume. No.
Well, listen, I don't want to wait any longer. I want you guys to hear this great conversation that we had with Oscar Nunez. So why don't we take a break and we will be back with Oscar in the studio. Yeah. G'day, I'm Justin Wolfers, host of the Platypus Economics podcast. If there's one thing I've learned from a career teaching economics, it's that your life is shaped by economic currents you'll never see. A single price tag can explain things a thousand experts can't.
People who understand economics, they make better decisions in their careers, their finances, their relationships and their communities, and I want that for you. Listen to and follow Platypus Economics, available now wherever you get your podcasts. Oscar, thank you so much for joining us on the Office Ladies Podcasts here in studio. My pleasure. Here I am. I don't know. Listeners, we're not being filmed. These ladies are in an old-timey, traditional, beautiful building on the corner, high up. I was in the elevator with Angela coming up and she goes, you know what? Clark Gable played poker in the basement. What? That's where we are. Carry on. This man told me. There's an older gentleman on the fifth
floor who was telling me some history. This is very apropos. So surreal. And we're here and we are going to talk to you all about your character, Oscar Martinez. You know, the name of this episode is all about Oscar. No, I think I knew that. Okay. He did because we talked to them well. I told you. But first, we wanted to congratulate you on the success of the paper and on season two, which is coming out today. Okay, yes, thank you. Wow. This airs as the day. Season two is premiering on Peacock. Very exciting.
And then for season one, you were nominated for a Critics Choice Award. You personally. Yeah. Thank you. Oscar. I appreciate that. I appreciate that. Yes.
What has it been like to take this character from one series to another? You know what, Jenna? It's been seamless. It's been seamless. Because as all the characters, it's a solid character. We're all so well-developed the characters, every one of them. Yeah. So it's been seamless.
And I love playing the straight man. I mean, he's a gay guy, but he plays a straight guy, right? Yeah. And I love that. I love reacting to things. I mean, don't get me wrong. If they're like, Oscar, anyone on the office, I'm like, either Dwight or Steve, of course. But to play a straight person off these people is so.
So fun. Mm-hmm. And I get to keep doing it now. So I get to keep, you know, and it's a whole crop of new people. I have friends and they're new, you know, Donal, who is so talented. So talented. Who works with Steve. Yeah.
And Donald's in everything. Everything. He's like Emily Blount. He's in everything, this kid. And Alex Edelman, my new favorite stand-up. He's so funny. Jenna. Is he cracking you up on set?
Is he the fun? one on set? He's very funny on set, but he's very smart, and he's a writer. So he's not joking around all the time. Right. But he's super smart. I mean, crazy. I'm so in love with him.
Ursus, like, he's like your nephew. I'm like, you're right. I can't say enough about Alex. And we've gone to see him after, like, just for us, he did a show at the Ford, and he went and he did it with Ben Harper because he's a fan. And so they did a show together. He's more comfortable on stage than he is in Alex in real life. He's so good on stage and so funny.
I can't say enough about him. Anyway, Alex, Chelsea is a new friend. Chelsea is so delightful. She's been in the studio here and chatted with us. And we just love her. Adore her. Yeah, she's very cool. Adore her.
So you know what? Well, it's, you know, look, they all went through the Greg Daniels filter. They're all nice people. There's no bad, you know. That's right. So those are my new friends and more, but those are the ones that come to mind the most. And Bemi. And yeah, they're all.
I mean, yeah. I realize Jenna and I are now becoming the people that when people would interview us, like, who's the prankster? Who's the jokes? Oh my gosh. We're asking all the questions now that people used to ask that. That's crazy. It's kind of crazy. I know.
Okay, we want to ask you questions about Oscar. Yeah. We have some and fans wrote in really fun. I don't know the answers. We don't know all of these answers. And also the fans wrote in Oscar. And they're so thoughtful and they love your character. So we're excited to dive in.
This first question, I did not know the answer to. Okay. Okay. So we know that aspects of Oscar's character, like all of our characters, got revealed over time, that the writers would write to us over time. And like you said, fully flesh us out. Yes, ma'am. But early on, in those early days, when we didn't have all of that to work with, did you create any backstory for the character of Oscar? Like where he was from, his family, anything like that, how he ended up at Dunder Mifflin. No, what happened the way I approached it or whatever. I got the job because of improv because it was a good day for auditions for me. On that day, I had four auditions. So the time I got to the office, I just didn't care.
And that's the best way to go in. You were super loose. It was your fourth audition in one day. Yeah. So it was a good actor's day. I'm like, I felt like an actor that day. Because you could go a week and not have one. You're like, what am I doing?
So it was a good day. And then you go back more. And it's improv and that's what we do. And I don't know why, but in my mind, I was like the boss of our clump of Kevin, Angela, myself. Because of where I was seated. And I thought. But then as we started improvising and going, Angela kind of began. And I'm like, oh.
And so I was thinking about that. And I was like, okay, now I have to, I'm going to adjust a little bit, you know? Yeah. Because now she's at. I'm like, okay, so now we're like the parents of Kevin. That happened pretty like organically because. We started improvising over there in the clump, and I just sort of took high status because I was so prim and proper. And then you were just instantly annoyed with me.
It was perfect. It was organic. And you did it. And you snapped at me because you demanded, because you're like, you're talking to him. What happened? What did he say? And I'm like, you saw me. And then that was it.
That was it. And the writers were like, what? They're really good improvisers. We're like, yeah, that's what we do. And then they started writing a little bit more for us. Yeah. And Kevin said, were you guys talking about? You're like, nothing or shut up.
You just shut him down. I said nothing and you said almost the same thing at the same time. I go nothing and you went, eh. Yeah, like, don't worry about it. Like, what's, like, and he came in with that sweet, like, and the speed, he's like, where do you guys talk? And you're like, shh, no. Yeah. Well, I'm curious right now, who was the head accountant of that club?
I don't think they had one. We did. We figured it out ourselves. But I mean, who would you say? Do you think it was me? And she just started. You think it was you, Angela? I think I had to schedule everything, and I had to make sure everything got done.
And I feel like some of the invisible labor came down to Angela Martin. Oh, my God, I love this. I love this. So Oscar had the job, and you're like, but I am doing all the work. But I get everything done. But who does Michael go to? Oscar. But who turned in the paperwork?
Me. It works perfectly. Delicious. Because he's a misogynist, and he feels good that he's going to a lot. That makes him feel good. Look what I'm doing. Michael. Yes, as the character.
He's like... Which would make Angela be resentful of Oscar, right? That she's doing some work. Yeah, just another thing to be resent. But another thing of like, welcome to my world. Yes. Hello, ladies. We all, this is what women know this is...
I guess this is what I have to do. This is the workplace. Well, I have a question for you. And a few fans wrote in with a... similar question. They want to know if I answered the last one. You did. I think you did. I think you said in your mind, Oscar was in charge. Yeah, but in other words, I was in the moment. I wasn't like backstory, parents, none of that. I'm like, we're here. Like, we did the pilot. And then that second script came in. And I've said this before. And I'm like, who wrote this? Diversity day.
Yeah. And they're like, that kidding. I'm like, the kid writing the skateboard, that teenager, the sullen kid from Harvard. I'm like, oh, we're in good hands. Because this. script wasn't good. It was really, really good. That was a killer script. I'm like, oh, my God, this show. Yeah. This is good.
We didn't want to jinx it, but I'm like, oh, this is going to be good. Yeah. Anyway. Oh, no, I think we all felt that way. It felt like, you know, lightning in a bottle. That was a really good. And then the script was good, but then we were having fun because Mindy couldn't get through the scene when she's like, he's like, he's like, uh, put you, muly, muly,
and she slaps it, but she's not, she didn't act as much as we did this, so she's just laughing. And we're like, what's happening? Take 27 and she's like, I can't. And how could she not when he's in her face? Mugibu Kyi. I know. I know.
Okay, wait. So a bunch of people wrote in with the same question, which is, did you have a favorite Oscar storyline? Like if there. Storyline? Yeah, if you look back on like those nine seasons. I know it's a really tough question. No, no, it's not a tough question because the other day or six months ago, I don't even know anymore. I was watching the episode.
you're like, Oscar, and I have the draw open and I'm leaning on it. And you're like, I think the senator is having an affair on the floor. Yeah. And you dropped the drawer and catch it. And then that scene is so good, Angela. It's so fun. Because at the beginning, I don't know. I'm like, Blake.
Who's Blake? Yeah, who's Blake? Yeah, like, who's, what's with the yoga? I know, the yoga. And then I'm like, no, relax. And then you're like, we need to go. And I'm like, no, I don't want to go. No, we need to check it out.
First she was worried. And then I'm the one thing. She's like, okay, whatever. It's brilliant. I love that. It's so messed up. And then we go to the thing and we're spying on them and the stupid telephone. And your phone rings.
It's the stupidest joke in the world. Yeah. Terrible. Well, we got a lot of mail about that storyline. That's the writers, man. Those are the writers. If we can't make that funny, there's something wrong with us because it's all there. People were really curious how you felt, I mean, we know that it was very funny, but they were
like, were you surprised to see that Oscar Martinez would go behind Angela Martin's back like that? It's horrible. No one would do that. But it's a TV show. It's not real. So we stretch and we pull and we push the boundaries. It was horrible.
Who would do that? And then he's fine with it. I like Angela, but she can't keep her man. You know, it's just, but then I come back and I'm like, hey, stay with me, you know? Yeah. So it's a lot going on. Yeah. I was watching the scenes this morning where, wait, were they the ones at the fundraiser?
Yes. The fundraiser. Oscar, when you're just like, he's hitting. on me and then the journey that you go on. And then they're like, he gave me his card. The fundraiser. Jim's like, I think he gives everyone their card. Yeah.
And then at the end when he slides his hand down Oscar's sleeve, and then my favorite is you like to give him, why does this keep happening to me? That's good. And then you're like, oh, I feel so bad for Angela. I could not be happier. I could not be happier. I know. I could not be happier.
And remember, here comes the wise one who we think doesn't know what's going on. And he defend us, Kevin, on the porch. He goes, these are two good people. And you suck, basically, right? There was a scene who were leaving. And you and I are that like, we're just like hand towels that you can use. Yeah. And he's like, yeah, you kind of suck.
You suck. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's really cool. Great party. You suck. We have a follow-up fan question from Stephanie C. in Powder Springs, Georgia, who would like to know after all of this has happened and the Angela and Oscar. storyline, do you think Oscar still keeps in touch with her?
In the show? In the post-Dundermifflin world. Stephanie gives an example. She said, for example, would Oscar, even if it's just a Christmas card every year, do you think Angela and him exchange some kind of thing? Well, no, they do stay in touch because remember, who's the godfather of the kid? Oscar. Philip, yes.
Rain reminded me that on his podcast. Someone asked the same question. I'm like, why would Ray? Huck, and then Rain's like, oh, wait, aren't you? And I'm like, oh, snap, sorry. And I had to apologize to the person who asked a question. I'm like, it wasn't a ridiculous question. I'm the godfather of their kid.
Yeah. So, yeah. You have to show up sometime for something, some birthday or something. And also, Philip meant a lot to Oscar. If you look back on the finale, Oscar's holding Philip at the wedding. And then one of my favorite things is- And so did Angela. I think they do like staying in touch a little bit.
Absolutely. I loved it when Angela's laying out Philip's outfit for the day and Oscar comes in and goes, No, the best. Those shoes, are you kidding me? No, not over my dead body. Like a little baby shoes and like trades them out. Angela, I will call child protective. Child protective
services. The best line. Saddles denim and saddle shoes and it was a talking hat, I will call child protective. That's right. That's a good line. Yeah. Okay, we have some more fan questions for you. These are good questions. All right. So folks are very aware that you almost
never broke on the show. And there are actually a few Instagram accounts that feature the very few times that you did laugh. They're super funny. But we were curious, do you have a moment that you remember that was the hardest you ever laughed on set? Like something that really got you. Even if you didn't break in the scene. Oh, even if I didn't break in the scene? Yes.
Just like, what do you look back on? Like the minute they yelled cut and you were just like, oh. Well, the Santa Claus. Oh, yes. Little boy, sits on my, and oh, God. You know. The one where Ed had to dive behind the wall because he was laughing. We couldn't get through it.
And the things they would say is like, he's like, little boy, what do you want? And he's like, I don't know. And he's like, what, do you think of it? And then you think of it before you sat down and no one's ever asked me to sit on their lap before, oh, God, what do you? You know, and he's just thinking about it. What's he going to get? But he asked for it. Little boy sit on my lap.
And then one of the scenes that they couldn't use is he gets up and his legs asleep and he starts banging it. And that's when Krasinski is just like at his mercy sitting there. Yeah. But as far as cracking up, I think Steve cracked me a few times. But Ed Helms, what I think cracked me up most consistently. Oh, yeah? With his mugs, his faces he would do. I thought we're so good and so funny.
I said this before. The Andy Griffith show is an old TV show. Yeah. In black and white. And in the town of Mayberry, there's a barbershop. It's Floyd's Barbershop. And that character, you guys are too young, you're looking at me like, there's Floyd the Barber, and that character reminds me of Andy.
I don't know why. I want to go back and find, I mean, you know, those episodes are out there. My grandparents watch that show. You were supposed to my grandparents. Her grandparents watched it, Oscar. Did you watch it with her grandparents? No, no, no, come on. I have to look at my wife.
I have to leave. Oh, no. My grandparents. No, no, I'm not. My great grandparents watched it. Oh, Jenna. I believe it. Most people who watched that, I think, have died.
Most people. Because they're so, so old. I was really young. My only defense is I was really young when I watched it. You were three years old. Not really. I wasn't that young. Well, I do remember it, like, when I would go visit them in the summer, like, they would have it on.
And I remember the beginning because he whistled, right? Ron Howard is the little boy with the fish of old. Yeah. Yeah. We know it. Yeah. Okay. But I can't remember Floyd.
I want to go find him. But yeah, Ed gave really good face. Really good face. And he was well written. It was a very extreme, funny, funny, funny character. But see, I didn't know that till today, that the character that consistently made you break was Andy. And he would get away with doing things that Michael would.
He was a very extreme character, but anchored. And he was like, what is happening? And he did something. He's like thinking of something. He went like this to think. And I'm like, who did? Oh, I remember. I went like this and I couldn't.
Put his like fingers to his mouth. Yeah, like a steeple. And I'm like, no, I can't. And I started laughing. Mm-hmm. And then I remember he got her step up as a cat. And he went prowling around John Crizzynskin. He's like, who am I?
And John's like, oh, my God. I was watching the scene too where, you know, a lot of people go to Oscar for advice. It's kind of interesting. If you rewatch the office, Oscars who a lot of people go to. Because there's no one else. Everyone who else is. I know. I know.
Because he's the voice of reason. Jenna was smart and reasonable, but Jenna was in love. And she was in love. I didn't have time to give me. Pam. Or the inclination. You're like a nice person. I would tell it to them like it is.
You know what? I think that Pam, I'm not sure people wanted her advice because she seemed a little bit like she was a grounded person. But I don't think she had her shit together, right? Like she was engaged and then she's with this other guy. Is she going to our school? A little bit of a blade of grass blowing in the. window a little bit, a little bit. But Oscar was pretty anchored.
Much more stable of a person. But, no, I was watching the scene where Andy goes to Oscar. No, it's a vest. And it's like, let's say Brad Pitt gets on me. And then my talking is, it can't be my place. Surely this can't be part of my, like, work description or something that I have to. Like, you have to, like, secure him, like, make him securing his. Like, yeah.
That was a funny episode. and that's, again, Ed Helms. Yeah. Is there a character you wish Oscar had more scenes with? Is it Andy? Oh, that's a good one, probably. I always say Steve, because he was so good and it was so fun.
And I had some scenes with him. Oscar and Michael had a lot of great moments. We had a lot of great moments. A highlight is from the surplus when you have to explain what a surplus is to end. Oh, my goodness. The lemonade stand. I don't know how you kept a straight face Oscar,
because, you know, as your character, you're laying it out like the math of it. And then you're like in the next year, and Steve is my call goes, I'll be six. Like he's missing the point altogether. But he's on it. He answered quickly. He's on it.
And it's, you know, it just struck me too that Oscar gets advice and all that. But when push comes to shove, he's such a know-at-all. But sometimes he gets putting a position where he fumbles the ball, which is very human. Mm-hmm. You know, like I was in a. room with like men or something CEOs. We might have gone on a trip to three of us, Andy, and I got a chance to like speak your mind and I fumbled it.
And I was, you know, which happens. A shareholder meeting. Yes. Which is very funny. Yeah. Yeah. Well, speaking of the surplus, that is one of my personal favorite Pam Oscar storylines. Right.
And I love it because often we were allies because we were the reasonable people in the office. That's right. Now here we were like adversarial. Because you wanted the chair? What did you want? You wanted the chair. You wanted copier. So I'm asking you now, Jenna to Oscar Nunez in real life, would you choose new chairs or a new copier?
Oh, Martinez says copier. Nunez, I think says chairs. Thank you. Chairs. We all know it's chairs. Yeah. I feel as passionate about chairs as Jenna as I did as Pam. Okay.
I think it's chairs. Let me say, I've had real jobs and I wasn't a good worker because I would pick chairs over a copier. Martinez, the pragmatic thing would have been copiers. But here, I'm with you, chairs. Have you guys ever had to make a lot of copies? Yes. I did. I worked in a mail room and like having a shittie copier is a huge time suck on your day and extra work.
Yes, I had to collate giant things using a copier. Yes. I still pick chairs. There would be paper jams. You have to open the whole thing up. But in Jenna's defense, am I imagining things? Jenna spent a lot of time in her chair because she's the receptionist. And she can't get up and mess around like the rest of us.
As Pam. As Pam. Yes. That's right. As Jenna, I worked in offices and I had to use copiers all the time. And I still would pick chair. Wow. Do you remember the one super sh**ty chair that was on set?
Yeah. Sometimes you would come to your desk and it would be at your chair. He'd be like, who the hell swapped? And then I would... It didn't have arms. It didn't have arms. And I would often get to set before Crete. And give it to Crete who wouldn't be able to tell the difference.
I would scoched it over to Crete. Of course you did. Sometimes I'd watch them sit down and kind of look around like, huh? Poor Crete. And you know what? It would come back to accounting. Someone would move it around. But there should be a shit chair on the set.
There should be yes. Yes. And no one tells you. You just all figure it out. Just like an office. Just like an office. That's right. Well, I have this fun question from Ramona K in Ohio.
I'll be the judge of that, Ramona. Ramona says, Dear Office ladies, my favorite Oscar scene is when he is waiting for Matt to come to the bar and he gets a little tipsy. He then plays basketball very poorly and it always makes me laugh so hard. Whenever Oscar plays drunk, it is hilarious. Thank you for making the best show and podcast ever. Oscar, did you love that scene? A follow-up is, did you have any tricks on playing drunk? It's not easy to play drunk.
It's not easy, Ramona. Thank you for that. I appreciate that because it's not easy to play drunk. You also had to play drunk when you went on the business trip where you guys call Angela. Also, you had to play drunk when you went to Robert California's house when you got super drunk on wine. That was super drunk. Wait, what are we learning about the character of Oscar right now? You're drunk quite a bit.
He likes to twist off. Have you done drunk on the paper yet? No, not yet. Not yet. Within nine seasons. Yeah. That's a lot. I like the drunk that I was when I called.
you. Yes. But at Robert's house, I was really drunk. Yeah. Yeah. That was a crazy episode. How do you do it? Yeah, the drunk, when Oscar and Andy call Angela, I thought that was like the perfect kind of drunk.
I did too. I agree. You still had some hills and valleys. Yeah, yeah. Wait, are you saying that's the drunk you would want to be? No, no, no. No, it's good to play. To play.
It's fun to play. That's the perfect drunk. When you're like still a little happy or a little buzzy. But you're a little spicy and you're a little spicy and you're a little spicy and you make really bad decisions. Yeah, like, oh, I love this ranking of the drunks. You know what? It is good.
The drunk you don't want to be is the Robert California House drunk. That's like, you're not feeling good the next day. No, no, no, because anything could happen. That's not good. But I was just saying, like, I feel like you still had different choices you made at different times. That's right. Yeah. And that's when it's fun.
You think about being drunk, you think about when you've been drunk and then pull it way back. Pull it way back. Because if not, it gets weird. And you might not be able to pull it off. I've seen people who can't do good drunks And you're like, oh no And then I've seen people who play really good drugs
I can't think of any off the top of my head Who else had to play drunk on our Just me? Oh, you know Surely there was someone else I had to do drunk at the Dundees Oh, that was like fall off a stool Yeah, but you were happy drunk
That drunk was the same drunk that called you Yes, and also John, as Jim had to play drunk He drinks with Karen, he does shots Yeah, and then he falls off his bike. Yeah. That's right He's trying to bike home. That's right.
Yeah, John does that well Well, he's from Boston And of course, I think We had a lot of drunk Meredith Oh gosh. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Kate's seen with Michael when he's trying to get her to rehab And he's tackling her in the parking lot And she's like, wait a minute, wait a minute, wait a minute. Just amazing. And the whole thing of like taking a dog to the vet And he's like, we'll go into a bar
And she's like, you just passed it. And he's like, this is the middle. And finally she gets it through her head. Oh, that's the best. Guys, I think we should take a quick break and we're going to come back. We have even more questions, Oscar. Will you stay with us? Oh, my Lord.
Yes. Okay, great. Right, Oscar. Oh, my gosh. We are back. Oh, wait a second. We didn't take a break. What a fake out, you guys.
Do you want a break? The break was two seconds. I'm pulling the chair back. I'm like, time's a stretch. We can. No, it's okay. You can take it out. Keep going.
Keep going. This has nothing to do with your character. What do you do for fitness? You look fit. What do I do? I mean, you did hang upside down on the office. People have asked if you really did that and you really did that. I did.
I'm taking a little bit of martial arts, just a little bit, which I like. I've always done it off and on my whole life. What kind? What kind of martial arts? Right now it happens to be Hopkito. Okay. And yeah, I love it. I love it.
And it's a little strange because this particular thing is two hours classes, which I've never done before. It's usually one hour, but this guy does two hours. So that's what we do. And I did it yesterday and I'll go tomorrow. Are you so wiped after? I mean, sometimes I play tennis for three hours. I'm a little wiped.
That's a lot of, yeah. And also, I have a daughter, Jen and Angela, no, and she's in the school, and they were doing the importance of being earnest and so cute and adorable. And there was an intermission or whatever, it was over. And a dad walks in, this guy walks in. And his daughter's in the thing, too. and he walks and he comes up to me and he might be in his 40s
and he's sweating and he's got like a backpack on and he takes it off in it. I can see it's heavy and I'm like, what are you doing? He's like, I'm like, you're hiking? It's like, no, it's a rucksack. It's a rucksack.
And it's like this camouflage backpack. And he says, it has weights in it. It comes and you put weights in and you walk with it. You're like hike with the backpack on it. It's like the women with the weighted vest. I see it everywhere.
Yeah, but it's a backpack. Okay. And he proceeds to pitch this thing to me. He's very excited about it. By the way, it was 50 pounds. I can barely lift it. I'm like, what is going on? He's like, yep.
And I like, hey, man, and I put my hand on the shoulder, and he felt like a rock. And he proceeded to speak for 30 minutes straight about this thing he's doing. So we get home and I'm like, Ursula, order me a rucksack, 20 pounds to start. And I don't know why, but now I'm doing it. You are? So people who are listening, they know it. And it's all, you know, bros do it. And men who are taking too much testosterone in their 60s.
And they put this thing on and it's all camouflage and black and flags. Oscar, we buy everything. I bought it. I bought it. I bought everything. I have the weighted vest. Jenna, this morning. No, lady, this made me laugh so hard this morning.
This is so funny. I was on the gram today and I got fed this thing. It is a neck massager that is supposed. going to tighten my jaw and jowls. So I want to read our text exchange this morning, okay? This is my first text to Angela this morning. If you speak about it for 10 more minutes, I will buy it. This is at 9.47 a.m. I just bought a neck massager off Instagram that is supposed to make your jawline look tighter without surgery. I, in my pajamas, pick it up because I've bought it, but she doesn't know. I take a selfie and I say, you mean this one that I bought
last month. Fish in a barrel, ladies and gentlemen. Same exact one. Send the office ladies. Jenna says, whatever crap, they'll buy it and put it on their bodies. And me too. I shouldn't.
Gina goes, oh my God, did it work? I said, no, but you do get a very deep sort of shoulder massage. It's kind of painful for me. She goes, have you been doing it every day? I said, no. Also, it doesn't really fit my neck. Josh is able to get a great neck rub out of it, but my neck is too small, so instead it just squeezes the shit out of my shoulder.
So how did you hear about this? It got fed to me on Instagram. Same with me, and I didn't tell you, but I had already bought it. I wish I texted you first. But I thought, surely I'll be the first one to try it. You took a chance. You took a chance. Let's get back to some fan questions here.
Oscar, you are a famous member of the Finer Things Club. It's so fun. The paper, you start making puzzles for the newspaper. I mean, you win a whole award in the last episode for your puzzles. Are you into either of these things in real life? Books or puzzles. I'm into books. I'm into puzzles, too, but I'm more into books than puzzles.
But the Finders Things Club, isn't it also art and the appreciation of art? It is. It's a book club, too. I feel like it's mainly a book club. I think so, too, because we discussed the books. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, what are some books that you are liking right now?
Oh, I'm always... Or that you've liked recently. Oh, let me see. I'm reading because I'm flying hither and thither. And I have Dave Sedaris's new book, which is always good. I love David Sedaris. Yeah, he's very funny. And it's easy for flights and stuff because it's short stories.
We were in Limerick Island, and I picked up an Agatha Christie book just because I was there. I love it. It's a murder mystery. It's very silly and funny. And I'll try to pass it on to August when I'm done with it. Well, we thought this was a really good question from Megan B from Silver Springs, Maryland. That's kind of a thinking question, Oscar. I like Marlon.
Megan says, why is Oscar at Dunder Mifflin for so long? Throughout the series, he seems to gain confidence and outspokenness and is clearly one of the more capable employees at the branch. So did Oscar have a backstory for staying? Oscar is unique and also the same as everyone else. Why do people stay where they are? They get complacent. They get comfortable.
You have a job every year. so you get a raise. Why take a chance? Why go somewhere else? Know the devil you're with whatever that saying is. He's got friends. He's established. He's not 20. He's not 19. He's done. He's comfortable. Yeah. If he went hunting, if something horrible happened, he's like, I got to get out of here. Then he'd get a resume and get a headhunter and do all that stuff that you have to do to find a good job somewhere else that's comparable. You don't want to go backwards. Yeah. And also, in this day and age, you're going to leave and go looking for a job and you're up against 20-year-olds and stuff? Yeah, at that age. That's very true. You sort of hit a plateau and you're like, well, I've got a good thing.
Jobs aren't easy to come by. We did have a fun fan catch from Savannah Ellen, Virginia, who said this. During suit warehouse, Oscar can be seen typing an email to the New York Post. I paused to read the email and it said, quote, this would be the perfect job for me. So she spotted an instance of you may be being interested in working. at a paper before the paper. What's her name? Who is it? Savannah. Savannah from Virginia. Savannah, you should be a PI. I don't know what is happening. You have proof of me typing for another job? Yes, that this would be the perfect job for me. And what I love about this is that there are always these moments. In our rewatch of watching the office, there would be some little thing that is background, that is like, nothing.
nothing of significance that the writers wrote or that you see on our desk. And then later there's a whole storyline. And fans will write in and say, was that foreshadowing? Did they know five years before that Jim was going to play guitar or whatever it was? And the answer is no. But I think somewhere the answer is yes. We have to get. Somewhere.
We have to get the savannas of this country and the world together and throw them a parade because this is insane. Isn't that amazing? They take a picture and they're like, this happened. Savannah, good for you. I don't know. I don't even remember this. I think there is something about this creative group mind,
how sometimes you put something in the universe or in the universe of the show, whether it be writers or crew or performers. And without you even realizing it, it starts to inform you. Like, I remember Rain as Dwight opening up his desk drawer and setting up his desk for the day and he's doing little drummer boy. Remember? Yes. And then all those years later,
then Angelus sings that particular song at the Christmas party. So it's just those little moments. Yeah, but that wasn't like consciously in the writer's heads at all. No, no. But it seeps in, right? Like somewhere someone had this idea that Oscar might like to work at a paper. Yeah. And they created this prop for you.
And now here you are on the paper. Which brings me to this question. Rachel Y in Spring Lake Michigan said, what do you think happened to Oscar in between the finale of the office and the pilot of the paper? If my math is correct, there is an approximately 12-year gap. Rachel would like to believe that you were just an involved godfather to Philip for most of the intervening years. And then also, Kristen C from Somerville, South Carolina said, what is your story for how you ended up at the paper?
Like, how did you get to Toledo? Rachel, I think it's 12 years, but I think in the paper they made it four? I think, am I wrong? So you stayed working at Dunder Mifflin after the finale, even though you were going to become a state senator. You think that didn't happen? I think he lost. He must have lost the election.
So he stayed at under Mifflin. And then got scooped up. Oh, right. Yeah. When the company was bought out. Yeah. And he just continued that same desk job and followed it to Toledo. Yeah.
Yeah. That's what happened. I think they probably got offered more money. He's like, Toledo Scranton. Eh. And he went to Toledo. I mean, he's kind of a workaholic. And for all his whatever, whatever, he played.
He plays it pretty safe. Yeah. He's pretty conservative guy. There's people like that. I have a cousin like that. Very by the book. Very smart. A doctorate.
But will not bend a rule if you paid her a billion dollars. Yeah. And he's kind of like that. He's comfortable with that company. Yeah, he's a little boring, too. He thinks of himself as sophisticated and whatever, but kind of a little boring. Right? He is.
He's very conservative, isn't he? He is. He is very conservative. Yeah. He's not a big risk taker. No, he's not a big risk taker. Finder Things Club. That's the risk. Look at us. We're in barraise. Yeah. We're in berets and whatever. Okay. We have this question from Caitlin P. and Wakeman, Ohio. And Caitlin wants you to know that's an hour east of Toledo. I thought so. And she says, this is not so much a question, but my office loving heart needs to let Oscar know how much I love his reaction to Michael's sad scarecrow that he gives him before he leaves and how Michael then loses his.
mind because he knows it's terrible. So it made my heart extremely happy when I saw that Oscar still has it on his desk at the paper. Why do you think Oscar brought it with him? Because that's from his boss. And, you know, let's face it, all the people at Dunder Mifflin, they're friends. And Michael drives him crazy or whatever, but they'd be the first to be there if he gets a broken leg and is at the hospital. Guess who's going to visit him? His co-workers. Yeah. Yeah. Oscar and everyone. even Toby would show up. I mean, I'm a bunch of this thing. I don't like it, Toby.
I'm allergic to daisies or whatever. And then he'd say something weirdly nice about him after he left. They're like family. Yeah. Yeah. I think so. That's why he has it there. My old boss.
Shelby B. from St. Charles, Missouri, said, Oscar has such a distinctive dance style. He shows it off at Jim and Pam's wedding. And also during the dance, the whole office does to Boogie Wonderland in season nine. it's sort of like a robot, but with more flair. I was just wondering, where did the idea for this dance style come from? And how did Oscar think it fit in with his character's backstory? Well, he's gay.
Okay. And he's that age. And for those fellas, there's only one. And her name is Madonna. Oh, he's doing vogue. The vogue. He's voguing. He's vogging.
Yes. Come on invoke. Yes, that's exactly what he's doing. And that video is back. Bad ass in black and white with those gay Puerto Ricans, Vogueing with the wind in their hair, and they got the attitude. Yeah, and she has that badass. Yeah, man, this is the best.
You are so right. That's his version. He's not great at it. No, he's not 20 years old anymore. But he remembers. He remembers. His whole heart. He's doing the dance theory.
That's right. We've talked about this before on the podcast, but the three of us have been known to close down a dance floor. Well, one particular dance. This is true. I was just talking about the off. Beyonce. Beyonce. All the single ladies.
That's a long time ago. Yeah. That's how long we've been. Yeah. You guys. And you are a very, very good dancer. I literally was in Studio 54. I went to Studio 54 at 17 years of age.
The Studio 54. Not a lot. I got in once or twice. That's amazing. I would have to go in with Eddie, my cousin. I couldn't go in by. myself. I'd be out there waiting like an idiot all night. I wouldn't get any. Would you dance?
Oh, yeah. Studio 54? Yeah. But I only went once or twice. Yeah. We used to go to the limelight or infinity. We can get into there. The only way I got into Studio 54 was if Eddie was with me, my older cousin. Well, when we do, Beyonce's all the single ladies, we should mention that you do take the lead. You are the center. You are the center. You are the center and we follow you. Now, Jenna's a really good dancer. As it should be, we all are, you guys. Let's not fight. I am, listen, I'm not fine.
You guys are actually good dancers. I have to follow you and like kind of count in my head. But I, you know what? Jen and I are looking at each other and not. I'm not saying that we have to do this, but I feel like maybe before we leave, we should video ourselves. This could be horrible. It might be bad. Maybe it will never see the light a day.
Oh my gosh. Maybe for one. I mean, who knows when the three of us will get a chance to do Beyonce, all the single ladies. No, we will. at a party. Oh, let's do it. In private. I don't know if we should put it out there. Go ahead. You want to film it? Go ahead and see what it looks like. I don't know. One day, one day we're going to do it again. No, we should go. We should have a party somewhere. Let's be glammed up. Well, speaking of your dancing, many people also wrote in saying how much they love you in the proposal. This is another dance scene. 20 years ago. Oscar. People will say, do that now. I'm like, no. I'm not going to do that now. Oscar, you're so funny in that movie. 20 years ago.
I want you to know we got a lot of mail for you for this episode. People were very excited that you're coming on the podcast. 50% of it was about the proposal. She's not kidding. It was a great role. It's a good rom-com. People want us to watch it on Office Lady 6.0 and break it down and then have you back on to tell us behind-the-scenes stories.
Sure. Oh, great. That's a date. By the way, for those of you who probably everyone knows this, I'm not saying anything, but as talented as Sandra Bullock is, that's how nice a person she is. I can't speak enough of her. She's a wonderful, wonderful kid. Well, you'll have to come back because I haven't seen that movie since it came out.
I have watched it since because it is one of my favorite rom-coms. Oh, and man, we went to see Steve in a 40-year-old Virgin, and you guys came out to see me in the proposal. Those were haddy times. That was fun while we were on the office. And the thing is, you didn't tell us, and well, wait, we'll wait until you come back on to break it down with us. Because there was a moment when we were all at the premiere that I just remember being like, ah! Well, Laura was really, she kept looking at me like, Oscar, I'm like, that's what I do. I don't know what you thought I was.
Yeah. I was in the ground wings. I knew that side of you. You knew me. You knew that apart of me. But a lot of people didn't. Well, that's the cool thing about you as a performer, Oscar. And I know you were saying that you love doing the paper because you play the straight man, but you do also play the funny guy.
Oh, I love it. You can do both things really well, which is unusual. Thank you. Yeah, I love comedy. Yeah. I love it. Love it. Well, before we go, can you tell us a little bit about what we can expect on season two of the paper?
Oh, I think it's funnier than season one. But the relationships keep changing and we have some really funny guest guy who comes on and he's in an office somewhere else. I don't know if I'm allowed to say who he is. Oh, that's fine. I like that. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You'll find out who he is soon enough. And it's really good.
I like the first season. I think the second season is funnier. And Jenna just informed me it's coming out today. Yeah. So in the finale, your character, he wins this award at the Ohio Journalism Awards. And when you accept your award, you dedicate it to the documentary film crew, who up until this point you have been annoyed with. You're annoyed that they showed up this new place.
So is your character more open to participating in season two? I think, yeah. I mean, you can't hit that note forever about, I don't want to be filmed. But at some point, at some point, right? You're like, I have to be okay with this. You're going to give yourself an ulcer as the character. Yes. Yeah.
But I like that they showed a little passage of time there where he got used to it. Of course. Because then as the audience, now I believe it, I'm on board. I get why he's softening. And it's funny to be like, oh, no, where do you guys, you know, all that stuff. Gosh, if you had been followed for nine years and you finally shook that and then you saw them walk in the door again, what other reaction could you have? You're like, what is happening? Yes.
Yeah. Amazing. Oscar, this is just so fun seeing you because we just love you. And, you know, I was recently asked a fan question, what was some of my most meaningful scenes to do in the office and the most fun I had and my favorite scene partner. and I said, obviously, I loved working with everyone on the office, but my favorite scene partner was getting to do all of those scenes with Oscar and us, just the journey our two characters went on. And I'm so proud of that.
Thank you. That relationship, and you're so good. And I think the only reason that I was able to do that is because of you, what you gave me as a scene partner. And you are one of the reasons I think, Angela, Lamarton didn't just stay one note. You know, your character's storyline brought so much out of my character and helped me discover new things about my character.
And you're just so talented. Thank you. Right back at you. And again, the writers gave us that opportunity making those stories. But, I mean, seeing you on the set, people don't know. We've known each other like you were working at a 1-800 thing. And I was away. And we were doing-
We were doing improv, you guys. be at the theater, like hearing L.A., wearing stupid wigs and stuff, and then to be on the same set and not know it. Yeah. That's like, and then on top of that, Ed and Brian going to the same high school and many people were at the same university, but you and I knew each other here working, and to meet there is pretty magical. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. And we still know each other. And we still know each other. Yeah. That's one of my favorite storylines. And, you know, people ask us a lot. What was it like when Steve left?
And your storyline is an example of, I think, something that we got maybe because the character of Michael Scott left and they went to our deep bench of talent. Yeah. And they wrote really great storylines for characters that before when we had this very much lead character, those second two seasons of the office, there wasn't like a single lead of the show anymore like there had been before. And I actually thought that was a really smart way to handle it. But instead, we got these really cool storylines that, I mean, it gives me chills some of your scenes together. I just absolutely love it. And I think it's one of the highlights of those later seasons.
Aw, thanks, lady. And the thing that was done, for all the hilarity of the show, when you have scenes like us, like, you know, hey, come live with me. And Jenna saying by to Steve at the airport. and we don't hear what they're saying, those are really cool moments. That's really, really beautiful deep stuff.
Yeah. You know, and Craig and Amy and Steve driving to wherever Colorado and the truck when he's going with her. Those are really emotional. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Amazing. These are beautiful things. And you're like, wow. Oscar, thank you so much for coming. You're welcome. Thank you, Oscar. Going down memory lane with us.
It was wonderful. I don't know the specific. What's the fee? What's the payment? What do I... I didn't get any... We will send it. Seriously, I love you guys.
This was so much fun. I'll come back anytime. It was great. Thanks, Oscar. I love you. Well, thank you so much to Oscar for coming in the studio with us and hanging out. You know, we have talked to him before on the podcast,
but it was over Zoom. So having him here was just so special. Really special. And everyone, be sure to check out the Paper Season 2, which is now streaming on Peacock. We'll see you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies.
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.